we don't even know where to go anymore
to get legitimate news if we're looking
for it yeah so if you think about that
like what would you really want I think
that's one of the reasons Wikipedia is
really popular at least hopefully you go
to Wikipedia and you do get sort of an
understanding of what happened what's
the issue what's going on
um in a way that shouldn't sort of lean
left or right people do want that they
have a passion for that they they want
to they don't want to be fed one line
they want to understand the world again
not everybody yeah people are perfectly
content to live in a bubble but I
actually think even a lot of the people
who are perfectly content to live in a
bubble
um are victims of the bubble they're
living in but I think people you know
Aristotelian thinking you know sort of
people want to know they love to
understand the world
[Music]
um rather than just be fed an illusion